- [David] Hello, readers.
How do we know what is
true, and what isn't?
My mama always told me, "Don't
believe everything you read.
"Just because someone took the
time to write something down,
"send it off to be typeset and designed
"and printed in a book or
published on the internet,
"doesn't mean they bothered
to tell you the truth."
You should be skeptical of
all informational writing
until the writer gives you
a reason to trust them.
Honestly, you should be skeptical of me
until I give you a reason to trust me.
Who am I, after all?
Just some stranger on the internet.
Well, that's a little unfair, actually.
You probably knew about Khan Academy
well before you watched this video,
which means you have a sense
that the information we teach
is reputable or trustworthy.
So, maybe I'm already at an advantage
for you trustworthinesswise,
because you associate
me with an institution
you already have good feelings about.
When an author writes for
informational purposes,
they want you to believe that
they're telling the truth,
but you can't just accept that on faith.
No human being is so important
that they can't be bothered
to explain themselves.
Now, let's be clear,
that doesn't mean that
everyone you disagree with
personally owes you an explanation.
It just means that you don't
have to swallow their arguments
hook, line, and sinker.
So, how do we move forward?
We can't just go around
in a nightmarish swirl of misinformation,
never knowing whom to trust.
That's no good.
Society couldn't function.
Imagine looking at the weather report
and saying, "I don't believe you!"
And then, walking outside
your home in shorts
when the forecast calls for snow.
That would be terrible, for you.
The key is to ask yourself,
"Why should you trust
the weather forecast?"
Well,
forecasters are scientists,
specifically meteorologists.
Their job is to study weather
patterns and make predictions.
And that doesn't mean
they always get it right,
because they're making what
amounts to educated guesses
about the weather.
But their expertise
and their access to weather
monitoring equipment
make them likelier to know
what the weather's going to do
than the average person would.
And this is basically
the test you should bring
to all informational writing.
Good readers look for clues
to establish trustworthiness,
to establish that the author knows
what they're talking about,
that they've done the research,
that they're an expert worth listening to.
Someone who hops on YouTube
and says, "Here's why your
teachers are lying to you
"about the goblins who live in the moon,"
is someone that warrants some
skepticism, a little side-eye.
Also, how awesome would it be
if there were moon goblins?
And why would anyone want that information
to be kept secret?
Okay, when you look at a text,
you have to wrap your head
around three big things.
One, the main idea or the claim.
What is the author trying to say,
explain or convince you of?
Two, the evidence for that claim?
What are the facts, details,
or other pieces of information
that tell us that that
claim is true or accurate?
And three, the reasoning.
How the evidence prove
that the claim is true?
Okay, so let's imagine that
this conspiracy guy on YouTube
is trying to make the
case about those goblins.
Let's listen in on his argument.
- [YouTuber] I firmly believe
that there is a colony of
goblins living inside the moon
and the government is keeping
this information from you.
How do we know this?
Look at the moon!
See that little squiggle?
You were taught that was
just a crater, but it isn't!
It's actually the tip of an
enormous goblin moon base.
How do I know that?
The goblins told me so.
I have a special phone line
from my house to the moon goblins.
And through me, they can answer
any questions you've got.
Our moon door is always
open, the goblins tell me.
- [David] All right, so, what's the claim?
Goblins live inside the moon.
What's his proof?
What we think is a crater on the moon
is actually a goblin moon base.
What's his reasoning?
What backs that up?
He says the goblins told him so.
Now, is that evidence?
Or is that just something he's telling us?
Well, one way we can know
he's probably full of baloney
is that only he can talk
to the moon goblins.
Right, he says he's got
a special phone line.
They can answer questions through him.
We can't talk to the goblins.
We can't have access to
any of their information.
He's behaving like the information
is freely out there for
anyone, but it isn't.
You have to go through him.
So, can the stuff he's saying
be independently verified?
That is to say, can anyone
other than this person
prove that there are moon goblins
or that that crater is a moon base?
Are there photos or
video from those goblins?
And if not, why not?
This doesn't pass the smell test for me.
There's proof, but only I
get to see it, is not proof.
That's just made up.
When it comes to making arguments,
you have to show your work.
A good writer has to earn
the trust of their audience.
And a good reader has to make
a writer work for that trust.
"What does that look
like?" I hear you asking.
Excellent question.
Let's take a look at a piece
that does its homework.
Okay, let's read.
"There are some conspiracy theorists
"that claim that NASA's
moon landing missions
"in the late 60s and 70s never happened,
"despite the mountain of
evidence to the contrary.
"They claim that the
photographs were faked,
"the mission recordings were scripted,
"and the moon rocks were nothing more
"than ordinary earth rocks.
"Perhaps you are among
these conspiracists.
"If so, let me prove to you
"that the moon landings took place.
"Perhaps you are skeptical
of the US government,
"which was in the middle of the Cold War
"with the Soviet Union and
a shooting war in Vietnam.
"Perhaps you believe that
any information from NASA
"is therefore suspicious.
"Fortunately for you,
"there is plenty of third-party evidence
"that Americans traveled
to and landed on the moon.
"An observatory in the UK
that previously observed
"the Russian launch of the Sputnik probe
"used its radio telescope
"to observe the 1969 moon landing.
"The Bochum Observatory,
this one in Germany,
"also confirms that mission.
"Finally, present-day photos
"from many different space
agencies around the world
"have confirmed the presence
of footprints, rover tracks,
"and the lunar rovers themselves.
"In order for a moon
landing to have been faked,
"the rocket scientist
James Michael Longuski
"estimates that more than 400,000 people
"who worked on the
projects in some capacity
"would have had to keep
the conspiracy a secret.
"In his 2006 book
'The Seven Secrets of How to
Think Like a Rocket Scientist,'
"Longuski suggests that given
how complicated it would be
"to fake such a project,
"it might actually be
easier to just go ahead
"and do the moon landing
in the first place."
So, if you don't believe
the US government,
this writer is saying, let's
look at some other sources.
How do we know those sources are real?
Well, we have some names to look into
to independently verify it.
We've got this rocket scientist.
We have the name of
this German observatory.
We could look into and
verify these statements.
It's not just one guy
asserting that there's
goblins on the moon.
It's someone saying here
are some non-NASA sources
that can confirm that
Americans landed on the moon.
Be careful out there.
It's a wild world of people
who wanna bend your brains
and turn you against your neighbors.
Use your brain, your heart,
and your reading skills to fend them off,
as you develop your principles.
You've got this, readers.
You can learn anything.
David out.